How's everyone doing?
[STUDENTS CHEERING]
It's a goody bag.
Thank you for that.
It's a goody bag day.
It's a good day.
Related to the goody
bags, once again-- hello.
Once again, I want
to get these out
for you, because you got to
have them on a Friday night.
There's no real
better way to think
about spending your
time on a Friday night
than opening up a
brand new goody bag.
The topic of the
goody bag is related
to reactions, which is the
topic we're starting today.
But it's really also
related to acids and bases,
which is something we'll
talk about on Monday.
So I'm giving you
the goody bag today,
but I'll talk
about the goody bag
and contextualize it in
the lecture on Monday.
But as I said, today
what we're going to do
is we're going to start
a new topic that we'll
be talking about for the
next couple of weeks.
And that is the
topic of reactions.
And what we're going to
talk about is reactions, OK?
Now this falls under
the domain of something
called chemical
kinetics, which is
this study of reaction rates.
Kinetic, move, right?
So what's moving?
Concentration, right?
This stuff that you started with
is doing something and winding
up different.
That's a reaction, OK?
Now we've already written lots
of reactions in this class,
but today, we're going
to talk about the rates.
And the rate in particular
is the changing concentration
of the reactions and
products with time.
So there's a couple
of terms that we
got to know because we're
going to be working with them.
So I'm going to start
by writing those down.
So the first thing is
the thing that we're
going to talk about changing,
which is the concentration.
So the concentration is
equal to the moles per liter.
I mean, there are lots of
ways to write concentration.
This is the way we're
going to write it,
moles of a substance per liter.
Well, that has a name for it.
That's called them the molarity.
What's molarity?
It's moles per liter.
And then we can also
write it in shorthand,
which I'll be doing as simply
some substance in brackets.
If I say that I have some
substance A, and now I say,
oh, look, I'm writing
brackets around it,
then what I mean is the
concentration of A, OK?
That's what that means.
Which is the moles
per liter of A.
Good, so that's concentration.
What else?
Well, there's the rate.
There is the rate.
And the rate is, as you
might guess, the change
in the concentration with time.
That's the rate that we're
going to be talking about a lot
today, the reaction rate.
There's a change in the
concentration with time.
What else do we got?
Well, we have then a law.
Because see, here's the thing,
the rate is just the rate.
It's the change with
something with time, right?
It's like the change
in distance with time
would be like velocity.
OK, but what if I
wanted to say, well,
could you tell me what the
rate is as some function?
Right, as some function?
That's called the rate law.
And it will give me a
rate versus concentration.
That's what I want
out of a rate law.
And then, well, I
could integrate that.
I could integrate
that because the rate
itself is a
derivative with time.
It's a change in time.
So if I integrate
it, well then I've
got something called
the integrated rate law.
Integrated rate law.
And what's that
going to give me?
It's going to give me the
concentration versus time.
So the rate law is a rate
versus concentration.
And the integrated rate law is
the concentration versus time.
And then we've got Arrhenius.
Let's put it all
on the same board.
So I'll do one more here,
which is the Arrhenius
dependence for reactions.
And as you might guess,
this is going to give me
rate versus temperature.
These are the things we're
going to be talking about.
These are all the things--
all of these things
we're going to talk about today
in the context of reactions.
I wanted to get them
all down on the board
so you can see them
and think about them
and feel them as we go forward.
So there are a whole
bunch of things
that impact the reaction,
the rate of a reaction.
What is it that matters?
Well, concentration.
How much do you have?
That's the brackets
thing, right?
Temperature,
catalysts, the surface
and the structure that
you're doing the reaction on,
the solvent that it's in.
All of these things impact
how the reaction happens.
As you can see, I grayed
out, made a little darker
those bottom two because I'm not
going to talk about those two.
But I will talk about each
of those other items today.
That's our goal.
How do those items play
into these dependencies?
That's our goal,
to figure that out.
OK, so we're going to
start with concentration.
And we're going to talk
about how concentration
plays a role in reaction rates.
And we're going to start
with something very simple.
I have something called
A. Oh, it's purple.
And it turns into something
called B. It's green.
There you go.
There's a reaction.
OK, so let's start--
OK, so aA goes to bB.
Now the very first thing that
I can think about in this
is that nothing is lost.
Nothing is lost.
So I'm going to
assume that nothing
disappeared from my container.
You see that?
The container is there.
So I haven't lost any mass.
I haven't lost any mass.
Well, mass conservation
is a big deal, right?
So mass conservation-- by
taking this very simple case,
mass conser--
oh, really?
We could have a mass
conversation too.
That's OK.
That's kind of what we're doing.
But let's write it
as conservation.
This means that
if I take away A,
I must add B with the same
amount and not lose anything.
And if you look at that in
terms of these coefficients,
remember, these are
stoichiometric coefficients
as part of the reaction.
Then what that means
is that 1 over b
times the change in the
concentration of B with time
must equal minus 1
over a times the change
in concentration of A with time.
That is mass
conservation, just written
as changes in concentration.
You can see it.
Look, imagine just as--
imagine that this is 1,
just as an example, OK?
1H2 goes to 2H, right?
I'm not going to lose anything.
Those are my
stoichio-- well, OK,
this would tell you
that the rate of this
if I don't lose
anything would be
1/2 the change in H, the
concentration of H with time
equals minus the change
in concentration of H2.
That's just exactly what I
wrote, but with an example.
I didn't lose anything, right?
So the rate of change of
this must be twice the rate
of change at that, right?
Stoichiometric coefficients
come in and they make sure--
when I write it
this way, they make
sure I don't lose anything.
That's why you've got
to have these there.
Now there's a couple other
things about this, all right?
There's a couple other
things about this.
One is that you'll notice that
the rate is always positive.
Maybe we should write
that up on the top board.
Because it's a convention.
But we like positive numbers
when we talk about rate.
So the rate is
always positive, OK?
Always positive.
So when we have--
when we're thinking
about a reaction
where something's
getting consumed,
we're going to write it as
the negative of the change
in that concentration.
Because that's a
negative, and then
we're going to write it as
a positive of the change
in concentration of
things being formed, OK?
So the rate is
written as positive.
Well, there is
another thing, which
is we can go more general.
Let's just think about this.
If we go more
general, more general,
then let's have more
than just A to B.
Let's have aA plus bB
goes to cC plus dD.
So now I've got four things.
Two products, two
reactants, right?
OK A and B are the reactants,
C and D are the products.
And they've all got
their coefficients.
And so you can look at the
change in any one of these
and know the rate.
You could look at the
change in any one of these
and know the rate.
So if I look at this, then the
rate would be equal to minus 1
over a, great convention.
OK, it's a positive value.
That's got to be equal to minus
1 over b times the change in B
with time.
And it must be equal to plus 1
over C, times the change in C
with time.
And that also must
be equal to plus 1
over d, all right, times the
change in the concentration d
change dt.
Right?
So I could look at the way
any one of these things
is disappearing or forming and
because those stoichiometric
coefficients are there, I know
what the rate of that reaction
is.
Again, this is basically a
statement of mass conservation.
Ah, but there's more
because this is just
a definition of rate.
Rate is changing concentration
and it's always positive, done.
But I want a law.
I want to know
not just OK, yeah,
I see how you change with
time so that's a rate.
But I want to know a
law, that if I gave you
any concentration, if I gave
you any set of concentrations,
what would the rate be?
What would the rate be?
Could I come up with a function?
And so we write down
the rate as depending
on the concentrations.
Now, you can do this with
the products or reactants.
We're going to do this
with the reactants.
And so you would
have that it depends
on the concentrations
of a and b raised
to some power with
some coefficient.
So k times a concentration
of A to the m
times the concentration
of B to the n.
OK, so we're raising these--
Now, we don't know what these
are, but what we're saying
is that there's got to
be a way if I just know,
and maybe if I do some
experiments or something,
maybe I could come up with
a general function that
depends on just the
concentrations, wherever
they are of a and b.
And they're going to be
raised to some exponent
that I don't know
yet and they're
going to have some constant.
That's a rate law.
That's a rate.
OK?
Now, OK, the thing is
that the rate law--
let's go over to here.
OK.
So the k is, as you
can imagine going
to be very important here,
that's called a rate constant.
K is equal to a rate constant.
And this is going to depend on
conditions like temperature,
pressure, solvent.
So it's going to depend on
things like temperature,
pressure, solvent, et cetera.
All right?
And we'll see how you get k.
But m and n cannot come--
and this is very important--
m and n and k for that
matter must come--
Gesundheit.
--from experiments.
They're determined
experimentally,
determined experiments.
OK?
This is a mistake
that is often made.
You see, m and n must somehow be
related to these coefficients.
No.
M and n is something else.
I've created a function
that the rate depends on,
the rate of this
reaction depends on.
I've put these
exponents in there
and I'm looking for the
dependents on m and n.
And the only way to
do that, to know that,
is to do experiments.
You can't just get that from
the way the reaction is written.
You can get mass conservation
and the relationship
between rate, rate, rate.
Right?
Those are all the same.
But you can't get the
rate law unless you
do some measurements.
Now, then when you
do, then you can
get the order of the reaction.
So this is the reaction
order and that's
an important property.
There's one more thing
I'll say, and then
what we're going to do,
I'm setting the stage here
and then we're going
to do examples.
OK?
So don't worry, we're going to
go through different examples
that I think will help
crystallize these concepts.
But the last thing I want to say
in terms of setting the stage
is that the units
of rate, if you
look at how I've defined
the units of rate,
it's a change in
concentration with time.
So the units of rate,
the units of rate
are going to be
molarity over time.
That doesn't change.
Right?
That doesn't change, those
are the units of rate.
That's the definition
of the rate.
But you can see,
and we will see,
that if that has to always
be true, then the units of k
may very.
And we're going to see that
as we go through examples.
So the units of k could
be different and we'll be
depending on the reaction
order, which is basically saying
it depends on the rate law.
OK, setting the stage.
Now, let's look
at some examples.
And we're going to go
through this sequential,
we're going to do a
zeroth order reaction,
than a first order reaction, and
then a second order reaction.
OK?
So zeroth order.
Well, zeroth order
reaction, right?
So this is nitrous oxide.
So this is a reaction of nitrous
oxide turning into N2 and O2.
Nitrous oxide is used in
many, many applications,
not just laughing gas.
If we go with what
we just wrote down.
OK, so let's take
this example, I'm
going to write it down here.
2 N20 goes to 2 N2 plus O2.
OK.
Well, so the rate we know
from what I wrote down,
the rate is equal to
minus 1/2 times the change
in the concentration
of N20 with time.
But see, so now I'm
doing some measurements
and I'm plotting some data here.
So I'm plotting here the
concentration of all three
of these, the reaction, and
the two products with time.
And what you notice is if I plot
the concentration with time,
it's a linear relationship.
What does that mean?
That means that they don't
depend on concentration
because the rate is
the change right,
the rate is the change in
those with time, right?
The change in the
concentration of time
is always the same because
it's a straight line.
So if that's true,
then the rate from,
let's say, straight
line, straight line,
and we'll talk about
plots as we go,
straight line plot of
concentration versus time.
All right, straight
line plot, then we
know that concentration
is independent of time.
I'm sorry.
Rate is independent.
OK, hold on.
Rate is independent
of concentration.
OK.
The rate in the beginning is
the change in concentration.
The rate in the
middle is the change
in concentration with time
and it's a straight line
so it's always the same.
Well, that means something.
It means something in
terms of our rate law.
Because now I know
from my rate law,
that the rate is equal
to k, the rate constant,
times N20 to the m.
That's from here, right?
You take all the reactants
and you put them down
and you put exponents on them.
And so I've just got one,
N20 and it's raised to the m.
Yeah, but I know there's
no concentration dependents
of this rate.
So I know that m
equals zero and it's
a zeroth order reaction, rxn.
Oh, I've saved so much
time, rxn reaction,
which means that the rate
is simply equal to k.
The rate must equal k, OK?
So in this case the rate,
right, so we're continuing here
equals k.
And that means that k must have
units of molarity over time.
Why, because that's the units
of rate, the units of rate
don't change, the
units of k will.
But in a zeroth order
reaction, the units of k
have to be equal to
the units of rate
that there's nothing
else in there.
OK.
Again, I want to
emphasize, there
is no simple correlation
between the stoichiometry,
the coefficients of these
things and the rate law,
you've got to do experiments.
This data comes from--
Well look at it, there's the
mass conservation in action,
02, N2, all right?
You can see it.
You can feel it.
Slopes are different,
they must be.
Now, here's a reaction
some of you may care about.
So why does a zeroth
order reaction matter.
Why does it matter, because
that's the reaction of beer.
So ethanol, OK, but
we'll call it beer.
So what does this mean?
If I consume beer, if I
did, then the concentration
of ethanol in it, there it is
plotted versus time is linear.
That means, this
is very important,
it's a zeroth order reaction.
It means if I plot the rate
of the reaction, you see it?
There it is.
It's a constant, it doesn't
depend on the concentration.
But that really has a
lot of ramifications,
because if I drink a lot of
beer, the average 70 kilogram
person, it takes 2 and 1/2 hours
for the enzymes in their liver
to decompose 15 milliliters
of ethanol, one beer.
But look at that, so
that means that if I
had more than that
the body, it's not
dependent on how much I have.
The reaction of the
liver, the enzymes
that are breaking
this down is not
dependent on the concentration.
So if I load up a lot more
in there it doesn't matter.
There is a pipeline
and there's a rate
and it's not changing, well
that leads to consequences
to be thought about
when you drink beer.
But there's another thing
we can do with beer,
which is we can integrate it.
Right?
Because if we know that beer--
if we know that minus--
I'm going to say there's
some reaction that beer goes
to something.
So minus d beer, dt OK?
Assuming it has a
coefficient of 1,
is going to equal, that's
going to equal k because it's
a zeroth order reaction.
Right, it's a constant.
And so OK, now I
integrate both sides.
If I integrate, then I've
got the integrated right law
for beer, which is that
the concentration of beer
is equal to some initial
concentration of beer minus kt.
This is the integrated rate law.
That's the integrated law.
Notice what I've done,
I've gone from talking
about the rate of the
beer being the rate there,
which is a constant
to a dependence.
There it is,
integrated rate law.
The promise was that would get
me a concentration versus time
and that's what it did,
concentration versus time.
How did I get it?
Well, I had a rate law
and I integrated it.
And I'm not going
through the math,
but you put the dt over
here and you integrate, OK?
OK.
So that's an
integrated rate law.
Well, let's go to
the next order.
If I had first order and I
looked at the data for that,
then you would see if I plot
the concentration versus time
it would not be a straight line.
Why?
Well, because for a
first order reaction,
so now we're in first order.
Right, then what that means is
that the exponent here is a 1
or if I have two reactants,
the addition of them,
it's first order
total or it might
be dependent on two
reactants and its first order
in each of them, but then second
order overall because they're
multiplied.
Let's stay we the simpler
case of just one reactant A.
So if there's one
reactant, and let's suppose
A goes to some product.
I'm not even going
to write it out.
You know that the
rate is equal to minus
the change in the
concentration of A with time
and that because
it's first order
it depends on the concentration
raised to the first power.
That's what we said
first order meant, right.
I'm telling you this
is first order now.
OK.
Well, you can see that
if it's first order
it depends on the concentration.
And so that means that
you can see from that
and you can see from the plot.
If the concentration of A
doubles the rate doubles.
The rate doubles.
Why can't our livers do that.
No, they're zeroth
order, but there
are lots of reactions
that are first order.
OK, here's the thing
right, but the rate still
has to have units of molarity
change with time, right
molarity over time.
They can't have that
unless k units are k units,
in this case, are going to be--
So let's see, let
me write down--
OK rate has units.
The overall units are
molarity over time.
So now I've got
k times molarity,
that has to have units
of molarity over time
and so k must have
units of 1 over time.
1 over time, but that
tells us what the plot.
It helps tell us
things about like--
But the plots always come
better when we integrate.
If we think about the
integrated rate law,
then it leads to linearity,
which is something
we always want in plots.
Linear lines.
Straight lines.
Linear lines, really,
I just said that?
I did just say that.
I'm OK with it
because it's true.
But let's integrate this.
Integrated rate law.
So now, there's my right law.
Now I'm going to take the dt
over and the concentration over
and I'm going to
integrate and I get this,
A equals some initial
concentration times e
to the minus kt.
Notice the units,
right 1 over time.
That's good.
OK, or if you
want, you could say
that that's a Ln A
equals Ln a 0 minus kt
and this right now,
this gave it to me.
Because now you know that
if you plot Ln versus time,
if I have a plot of Ln versus
time, plot of Ln versus time,
then it's linear.
And we like linear and that's
what's plotted on the right.
So that's a plot
of Ln versus time.
And so you can kind of
go backwards and forth.
Like if I had a linear plot
with concentration versus time
you know it's zeroth order.
If I had a linear plot with
Ln concentration versus time
you know it's first order.
And you know that from
the integrated rate law.
Now, if you have data, how
do I know what the rate law--
I'm sorry, what the
reaction order is.
Often you'll just have
data, you study a reaction
and you get data.
Here's a very
important reaction.
This molecule is
called cisplatin.
Now, cisplatin is
maybe the most used
and one of the certainly, very
most important chemotherapy
drugs.
But it's not active
in this state
with the two chlorine's there.
You've got to get one of them
out and put a water molecule
there, so that with
the water molecule
it can go and damage
the DNA of the tumor.
That's the idea and it can't
do that unless this reaction
happens in the body.
And so you can imagine
that this kind of reaction
is extremely important.
What?
And the rate is extremely
important here, all right.
This has to happen in a time
frame that we know very well.
So this rate has been
studied very carefully
for this reaction.
And you can see, OK,
you can write down
numbers, how much
did I start with
and how much what
was the rate, and I'm
watching the rate change.
Right away you know
the rate changes
as the cisplatin concentration
changes, it's not zeroth order.
And the second
thing you know is,
if you take any two of
those and you take ratios,
then the ratios are the same
so it must be first order.
That's one way to know
what order you have.
All right.
Yeah.
So if I have data.
With data like that, with
data you could do this.
You could take ratios
at two different times.
And what does that get,
it gets you the order.
From that you can get the order
and we'll see another example.
And then, you can
go further than
that because then I could plug
in data from one of the times,
right.
Once I know the order I
could use data from one time,
from one time to get k.
Because once I know
the order, I know
how to write down the
rate law, and then I
can use any of these
lines to get k.
So we want to be
comfortable with reactions,
with rates going back and
forth between order, rate law,
integrated rate law, plots.
So if I had data that looked
like this I could do the same.
Here's another reaction, I
could say what order is it?
I'm not going to do
it, I'll just say it.
So you take any two
times and concentrations
and what you have
is that the ratio
squared gives you the ratio of
the rates, that means it must
be a second order reaction.
It means it must be, right.
I had something that
went into products
and the dependence of
the rate from this data,
the dependence of the rate is
that something's concentration
squared and you can
see it from the data.
So well, let's see.
I'm going back to
the middle here.
OK, so now, we just
went to second order.
So for second order
what do you have?
Well, you have that minus d
of something, some reactant,
and I just got
one reactant here,
if you think about it as
A. So the same thing A
went to something, OK, so minus
the change in concentration
of that with time is dependent
on k times the concentration
of that squared.
And if we integrate this one,
integrate then what do you get,
you get 1 over the
concentration of the something
equals 1 over its
initial value plus kt.
You can see that.
Take the t over here
and take this over there
and then that's going to
be the integrated rate law.
So now, look at that.
What do I plot to get linear?
I got get to linear, I don't
like curves in reaction rate
plots, I like linear lines
because the linear line
will tell me something
about the reaction order.
And by the way, the slope
could tell me something
about the rate constant.
Right?
And so if it's second
order, the plot
that gives you a
linear line is 1
over concentration versus time.
So let's look.
So let's say I had this
data and I try to plot it.
Well, the first thing I do
is I say, well OK hold on,
if I plot the concentration
versus time that's
what it looks like, not linear.
That means it's
not zeroth order.
OK, I'm going to
take the same data
and I'm going to plot the Ln
of it versus time, not linear.
Not first order, but if I
plot 1 over that concentration
versus time it gives me
a perfect linear fit,
so it must be second order.
Plots, order, linear.
OK?
We're not going to go
beyond zeroth, first,
and second order
because what I want
is for you to feel your
oneness with reaction rates
and kinetics through these
three orders, zeroth, 1, and 2,
and through these different
concepts that are up there.
So one more thing you can do,
before I turn to temperature,
one more thing you can do once
you know the rate law is you
can calculate how long it
takes for the concentration
to be cut in half.
If I know the rate law,
then I can calculate
the half life, that's called.
All right, so for example,
if it's first order
let's suppose it's first order
then the integrated rate law--
I'm just going to put the two
concentrations on the same side
here--
A over A0.
OK.
So the integrated rate
law gives me this.
It's just what I had
before somewhere.
OK, but you can see, well
what if the concentration of A
is exactly 1/2 of the
beginning concentration.
So when A equals 1/2 the
initial concentration,
but then this becomes a 1/2.
Right?
So if I want to know how much
time it takes to get to 1/2,
that's a good thing to
know just in general.
How long do I have until
half of this is left?
Well, then you know that this
is going to give you ln2.
When A equals 1/2 A0
then ln2 equals kt.
And we're going to
call that an important.
It's not just any time,
it's called the half life,
it's the time that
it took to get
to A being 1/2 of the initial.
So I've got it.
I've got it, I've
got the half life.
The half life is a
very powerful tool.
A number of you may have
heard of carbon dating.
This is just a picture
of wild animals,
but what happens,
those wild animals
breath in oxygen and other stuff
from the air including stuff
that contains a
spread of carbon atoms
and we know carbon has isotopes.
We know about carbons
isotopes, we've
already talked about
them, c12, c13, c14.
C14 has this wonderful
thing about it
that it radioactivity decays.
And it turns out that there's
a certain concentration of that
in the atmosphere
at any given time
and we can go back in history
and know how much concentration
there was in the atmosphere.
And we know if these
animals are breathing it in.
We know that they should have
that concentration at A0,
except this isn't a
concentration this
is a number of atoms.
But It's OK, it's still
a first order process.
The radioactive decay of c14
is a first order process.
And so, because of
that we can date,
we can date things using
carbon dating very accurately.
This is a really awesome tool
that relies simply on the half
life, on knowing the half life.
All right, here's a summary
that I thought would be useful.
This is it.
This is everything we just
talked about before we
switch to temperature.
Rate law, zeroth
order, first order.
And you're all like, why
did I write this all down,
it's all on this page.
No, it's good to--
Did somebody say, yeah.
It's good to write down, it
helps you think about things.
So here it all is.
There is the zeroth order,
first order, second order, OK?
Integrated rate law
that comes from that.
The units of the rate constant.
The linear plot to
determine the rate constant.
What gives you what the
slope of that line is
and then what the half life
would be if you just follow
this for the other two orders.
OK so this is all that
we just talked about
and the best way to feel
your oneness with this
is to do some practice problems
more than what we've just done.
The next-- really?
The next topic, I'm not going
to spend the same amount of time
on temperature and
catalysts obviously,
but I want to mention how
these impacts reaction rates.
We're talking about how fast
the concentrations change.
And to do that, what
we're going to do
is we're going to use the
collision theory of reactions.
And I've just written
it down here what it is.
What is the collision
theory of reactions?
What it is, is it says that they
occur when particles collide.
Why does a plus b go to c?
Well, because things collided
into each other and they
got close enough or they maybe
had the right orientation
so that new bonds could
form or others could break.
And the theory also says that
not all collisions result
in the formation of
product and that there
are two factors that matter,
the energy of the collision,
and the orientation
of the particles.
I want to highlight
those two factors.
So energy of the collision.
We're going to start with
the energy of the collision
and we're going to talk
about that in terms
of where you get that energy.
You get it from heat.
You get it from
thermal energy, which
means these things are
vibrating and moving,
maybe if it's a gas,
they're bouncing off
the walls of the container,
that's temperature.
How does that matter?
Well, in order to
understand how that matters,
we have to understand, we
have to think about this--
and this is what collision
theory for reactions
tells us to do is to think
about a reaction in terms
of an energy landscape
and an energy barrier
that you have to overcome.
So here I have this
Ea, which is the energy
that it's going to take.
I need to put that energy
in for the collision
to be strong enough.
Think about it as like, well
I just kind of didn't collide,
I had a very low
energy, so I'm below Ea
and I can't get over this hill.
It really is if you think
about it like pushing a car,
did I push it hard enough
so it can go over the hill,
or is it just pushed
a little bit, that's
the kinetic energy
we're talking about,
could it get over that hill.
Because what we're seeing
is that for this reaction
to happen there's some amount
of energy that's needed,
that's the activation energy,
that's the activation energy.
OK.
So what does that mean?
Well, first of
all, you should all
be feeling something right now.
And you know what I'm
talking about, I'm talking
about Svante, Svante Arrhenius.
Right, somebody said it.
You were feeling it.
Why, because I'm talking about a
process that has a barrier that
is thermally activated, a
is thermally--
Svante Arrhenius, crickets.
Crickets and then
intrinsic carriers.
Activated processes, reactions,
right, they have a barrier.
They have barrier.
Now here's the thing
though, Ea is typically
like maybe an electron volt, and
we know that KbT is 0.025 eV.
We've talked about this before
and how is that possible.
It's the same as what we talked
about before because this
is an average energy.
If you put the Boltzmann
constant in to room
temperature, This is
at room temperature--
If you put the Boltzmann
constant in at room temperature
you're going to get
that small energy,
but we know that thermal
energy is a distribution.
This is something we've talked
about, so here it is again.
So this is the
Boltzmann distribution
is what this
distribution is called.
And if I have my
energy for activating
a reaction, my barrier for
the reaction to happen,
shown there with
the vertical line,
it means that I have
two temperatures.
So yeah, kt may be small,
but there's some tails
out there where there is
enough thermal energy,
there's enough kinetic
energy for this collision
to lead to the reaction.
So those tails grow
larger and larger,
the amount of molecules
that have enough energy
grows larger as you
increase the temperature.
That is Arrhenius.
The probability for this
to happen grows, that is
what Arrhenius gives us.
And so here it is mapped.
This is something that
is in the textbook that
is a nice diagram because
it maps the two together.
You've got the reactant
going to the products,
there's an activated complex,
it needs that activation energy
and over there we've turned on
the side these kinetic energy
distribution plots.
So you can see, when
do I have enough?
Well, when I'm over
that activation energy
and there is going to be
some fraction of molecules
that have enough and that
fraction depends on temperature
and that is Arrhenius.
And so what we get is
that the rate, the rate k,
k the rate is equal
to some constant A
times e to the
minus Ea over KbT.
And remember, we use
Kb for one collision,
for a molecule or an atom.
We would use R or r for a mole.
Here I'm talking about a single
event, one molecule colliding
with another to make
the reaction happen.
Now, this is called
the frequency factor
and it's a constant.
Constant, constant,
and that's something
that you could understand
how this might depend
on a combination of things.
But it's assumed,
incorrectly, but it's
a good enough
approximation for us,
but it's assumed to be
independent of temperature
so we pull it out and call
it a frequency factor.
And it has in it information
about whether these things
really made the right
collision or not, that's
what A has in it.
This exponent,
Arrhenius is telling us
this exponent tells me about
that fraction, that fraction,
but A tells me
about orientation.
So here's an example.
Here's N0 plus 03, and on the
top line you can see the N0--
right so, the O's are
red and N is blue--
and the N0 is coming in, but
it's coming in either way
whether it's N or
whether it's 0,
it's coming into
the wrong oxygen.
It's hitting that
wrong oxygen and so
it doesn't do anything
because the one in the middle
isn't going to be
very reactive, not
at least at this temperature.
But then you've got
a different case
where it comes in a
little differently,
and in fact, the
nitrogen is what's
coming in and leading the
way to that oxygen on the end
and that leads to the reaction.
So you can imagine now it's not
just how fast they're moving,
which is what the exponent
tells us, it's more complicated.
Right?
And this is called
the frequency factor
because it's all these
complicated effects rolled
into the frequency of the
collision being right,
not just the temperature.
OK.
And so this gives us the
temperature dependence
of the rate constant,
this gives us
the temperature and dependence
of the rate constant,
which is very important.
This is not time,
this is temperature.
All right?
This is a different thing
than everything else
we talked about here, which
involved time dependence,
that's temperature dependent.
And finally, the last thing
and just to show you this
is my very last point,
is that just like before,
if I wanted to run a reaction
and make it go faster, one way,
just like with semiconductors
is to increase the temperature,
but I don't want to run
my phone at 600 Kelvin.
So what do we do,
we use chemistry.
I may have reactions that
I want to run a lot faster.
In fact, I very often
do, and what do I do,
I use chemistry and those
are called catalysts.
What a catalyst does,
and this picture shows it
in the context of
collision theory,
I've got these barriers
I'm trying to get over,
here it's flipped,
it doesn't matter.
There's a barrier
here, so the reactant
is higher than the
product, it's OK,
there's still a barrier
that I have to overcome.
What a catalyst does is
without being consumed,
what a catalyst does is it's
another material in there where
it allows that reaction to
happen with a lower barrier.
That's what a catalyst
is and you better
believe this is important.
So a catalyst lowers
that without changing
the temperature.
And in just 20 seconds,
here's my why this matters.
Catalytic converters is one of
the most important technologies
for pollution that has been
invented in over the last 50
years.
It's changed the game in terms
of what comes out of that car.
Why does it work?
It wouldn't work,
you wouldn't get rid
of these things,
these toxic things,
you wouldn't get rid of
them unless you ran it
at 1,000 degrees and you're not
doing that underneath your car
next to the gas tank.
But if you put the
right catalyst in,
all of those reactions to get
rid of those toxic chemicals
can happen much more
quickly and efficiently.
Right?
OK.
Have a great weekend.
See you guys on Monday.